paris maintenant le saturnisme est une
maladie qui provoque chez des enfants
des problèmes neurologiques
elle est due à une concentration
anormalement élevés de plomb dans le
sang
10% des enfants suivis apparaît dans les
centres de protection maternelle et
infantile en seraient atteints aucun
quartier n'est épargné elisabeth désolé
il y à des familles à risque
ces enfants sont peut être atteints de
saturnisme une analyse de sang dira
s'ils ont ou non trop de plomb dans
l'organisme à paris dans les centres de
protection maternelle et infantile
on pratique le dépistage résultat
environ 3000 enfants de 1 à 6 ans soit
10 % de ceux qui viennent en
consultation dans les pmi ont trop de
plomb dans le sang
il faut pour que d'intoxication dans un
appartement dans des parties communes
dans un habitat se produisent à la fois
atelier du plomb de plomb ancien des
peintures au plomb ancien contenant du
plomb soluble observables et que ce plan
est accessible donc ceci se réalise
lorsque les peintures devenue sèche se
décolle ou s'est paupérisée viennent de
la poussière les enfants intoxiqués
vivent en général dans des logements
vétustes antérieure à 1948 date à
laquelle on a interdit les peintures
contenant du plomb mais les quartiers
populaires ne sont pas les seuls touchés
à paris tous les arrondissements sont
concernés par le saturnisme et les
troubles divers
lorsque les quantités de plomb de
l'organisme augmente voit se constituer
des symptômes qui seront à ce moment-là
clinique et qui alerteront les médecins
ou les parents qui sont essentiellement
d'abord des symptômes sur la ligne et
sanguinet l'année mis des dollars domina
la constipation et surtout ce qui fait
la gravité de la maladie des troubles du
comportement atypique du titre des
sommeils agitation énervement ou au
contraire aphatie il faut prendre garde
à la peinture mais aussi à l'eau du
robinet si les canalisations sont en
plomb et au pot d'échappement
les enfants sont plus fragiles que nous
au